yacht au monde c'est squeeze aujourd'hui
on se retrouve sur garry's mod alors
vous êtes je sais pas combien d'avoir
demandé depuis des mois et des mois de
faire des vidéos sur garry's mod
et c'est chose faite la coupe la plus
dégueulasse du monde du coup aujourd'hui
je vais vous proposer un best-of de nos
meilleurs moments passés sur ce jeu sur
le mode murder et si je fais cette
petite intro si pour vous expliquer ce
que c'est que le mode murder histoire
que vous compreniez un peu quelque chose
à la vidéo sinon vous allez être un peu
comme ça et je suis tout ce qui serait
plutôt nul à chier un oui donc là dans
cette partie on va jouer à trois et à
chaque début de round y aura donc trois
roulent qui seront attribués alors il y
aura le rôle de meurtrier donc c'est un
mec qui ajuste un couteau et son but
c'est tuer les deux autres sans se faire
repérer le deuxième ex et l'innocent
dont qui sert il n'a pas d'armée ne peut
pas se défendre le but c'est juste
qu'ils sachent fois qu'ils trouvent qui
sait le meurtrier et qu'il lui dise à
l'autre innocents qui lui a un pistolet
et qui lui peut se défendre
voilà donc le mec avec son gain de sakho
est pas paniquer france je vous souhaite
un très bon visionnage et j'ai toujours
rêvé de dire ça à l'électrochoc taylor
kitsch et attend c'est bon je suis rien
non non non non c'est bien toilettes
hugo attend justement pousser à temps
voilà c'est là où elle était trop du bon
gars donc moi je moi je m'appelle oscars
voilà et je mérite un oscar que tu fais
avec ce mec il a un spasme essence ont
peu à peu et c'est normal dans les mecs
je vous préviens what has et romeo c'est
rob et moi si tu le vois c'est du lien
tu lui mets un coup de gueule direct
juliette romeo mito il s'appelle romeo
là c'est un gros mâle avec des bonne
grosse cote aaa en fait à temps qui
viennent pour choper le pistolet par
terre et tiens t'en occuper je fais une
alliance j'allais gagner
tiens toi là bas on va faire une
alliance non étalons cadets à l'e3
ok donc vous êtes tous les rides ensuite
je suis tout cela fait dix-huit acte
avec toi une forme avec tout ça c'est
moche on mer du nord
mais au niveau gamme et je remuais par
l'âge
on dirait on joue encore le mec qui sert
à rien [ __ ] ça ça veut dire que
septuor franchement alors je suis encore
fier mais j'aimerais dire tu es allé à
tort c'est qu'il tient qu'à moi c'est
moi là là que tu étais moi je suis le
meilleur et il peut provoquer
obrc ouais je suis encore le mec qui
vous est ce [ __ ] pour gameiro
l'art est mais que ça fait trop et se
fait quatre fois de suite là je suis pas
du tout le talent est arrête a réagi sa
mère moi c'est moi c'est moi je suis pas
de m'appeler arrête ça j'en alors mourir
pour elle laisse moi mais qu'est ce qui
plaît arrête moyen du fc mika rythme et
tu me fais peur une goutte a des
couilles ou pas trois fois de suite tu
vas tu avoir trois fois de fête manga
elle me tuez pas mais tu penses tu me
casses les c moi j'ai rien fait voilà
c'est moi rouge car c'est moi et je peux
rien faire contre toi ouais c'est ça je
vais te tuer non non c'est pas moi c'est
le cas quand je cours je cours forêt je
cours je m'en vais foxtrot
mais pourquoi mais qu'avez vous fait non
non c'est pas moi c'est pas moi j'ai vu
celui pas de faux pas mais celui je
ferai à tuer julie j'ai eu juste aurait
déjà j'ai lu dans une lettre aux
actionnaires
ses parents et s'est pas moisi est celui
palestine
je te dis que c'est pas moi cash et moi
j'irai j'aurais déjà pu tuer lui la tête
de wayne ce que je suis pas moi qui la
requête de jeu recul la tnt c'est pas
vrai a t il par des essais privés quand
il dit non
patrick est un manipulateur je suis
choqué je me regarde je suis l'arrière
je suis là du budget vient d'essayer de
trouver belle elle m'appelait la même en
représailles au non voyons ce que je
reçois je reste loin du luxe tu veux ok
chantonne le bruit de ta roulettes et on
clique
regardez l'afrique et pour les
techniques asie ont la technique
complète et regarde écoute quand on
regarde
averses italie j'ai encore le maître
inutile [ __ ] à lego lego
je t'appelais te plaît beaucoup bakou
bakou oui mais c'est la plus grosse
barricades de la balle à terre et
barricades vite barakat barricades allez
allez allez allez a battu barricades hop
le ninja le nid jack keir moitié tu
verras que c'est lui il convient bien
aux la série au royal et bertoua notre
mix et là oh là là tiens tiens un couple
doit clairement qu tiens tiens à ce
qu'on lui a mis mon gars il est venu il
nous a regardé mon gars il s'est pris
une balle dans ses pas là prête pas
c'est par ce biais leurs bus car tu sais
que tu as encore d'ayem qu'un l'arrêter
ou fait un beau diable et thomas un
psychopathe mon gars mais non mais non
les mecs là je vous promets que la balle
mais mika
ok on parie combien médiation meurtre
est allé mediaseine batterie
shadowgun là par contre les mecs je vous
promets que m non mais vraiment c'est
quoi la quand je vois les gars comme ça
veut dire que c'est vrai je suis le mec
inutile nongo pense ça c'est toi
non c'est pas moi c'est toi c'est par
toi tu sais bien c'est mika une goutte
et mica services itunes en tirer dessus
tiens là dessus mais qu'as tu avoir tiré
dessus
t'es mort oui vas-y match pas la nature
bouge pas kto moi j ai saisi teint hâlé
la cbk mais qu'at il en rajoute exprès
pour que je craque vas-y mais qu'as tu
viendras s'appelle michael il fait comme
tout à l'heure il fait style il attend
un effet trop le mail il attend que tu
me tues et ensuite il vient c'est
exactement ça par contre quand je
croyais ou non non dégage dégage de
cette confiance
beck
merci la confiance assez cool mais je
pas j'arrive pas à venir dans le passage
mois on merde à savoir qui sort un peu
sa tête ou hercule bons fous c'est pas
moi les gars je jure c'est ton petit
pull vert veut ou là où la houle ap ap
ap ap ap ap à la bouche c'est bon à
tanger avec toi
à la haye la parole je vous promets que
ce remake inutile
kovalchuk radio c'est pas moi qui ai là
ok je reste immobile audi l'asie tire
elle aussi habituée
vas-y vas-y pas plus à la tâte rohff et
on bat argent réel jeu mais quand je
vais utiliser comme mots clés tu le dieu
et la lumière allumée non c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi c'est pas moi c'est moi
c'est pas moi vas-y tire bâtir tu tires
tu vas te sentir tellement court mon
gars tu auras plus année mais qu'at il à
sortir de sa cachette vas-y tu perds tu
n'as même pas pendant la phase iib iii
j'espère mettre un petit temps de paix
tout donc un petit coin à l'épreuve
allait bien marrante astruc retard
tranquille il est l'arrière garde
bretonne premier en bd à la porte qu'il
ait accompli
paul patin mais pour elle épate elle
souffre elle pourquoi il ya des portes
1 pourquoi pourquoi des fortes parce que
le temps qu'elles s'ouvrent et ben tu
meurs
j'approche manoir tempête choix d'un
rush pas de moi tu viens cette approche
cheval ont fait un test de confiance
mais qu'un test de confiance
allez c'est parti je vais vers la non
non leurs amis et voilà lorsqu'on sait
que ces lots de penser que c'est l'autre
allés voter bien fait d'aller là bas ne
lâche rien il attend avec son couteau
rire le nom le mec je vais à sa graphie
le match soit sacrifiée breneck la
technique du l'heure elle est excellente
je prends le cas le vert ou le bleu et
voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de la
vidéo si vous voulez plus de gardes mode
comme cette vidéo je vous invite à aimer
la vidéo et puis à poster un commentaire
en disant je veux plus de charisme
en tout cas restez comme vous êtes parce
que vous êtes top et puis je vous dis à
bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo tout le
monde pis
eh ouais [ __ ] temps j'étais jardiniers
et joueur de golf ou si l étude pen pape
alors quoi